I had a question about backwards split
time rhythm and this always a funny one
oh I can use that statute um
grab your pie like this
and use your gonna do this like this
draw your play and make it so you've got
a clear center and you're gonna circle
backwards
so that you isolate the part in the
middle right is that not in the middle
I'm keeping in place so as I circle back
I know I'm making it truce with them
because if I lose a split time that
circle moves so I'm gonna stand here I'm
gonna east of that and I let my whole
body wiggle because if I'm wiggling my
right shoulders going forwards as my
left shoulders going backwards and that
makes it kind of inherently split time
so it's long as one arm is going up
while the other is going down and one
shoulders going forward while the other
shoulder is going back I have split time
I just get it's like you're pedaling a
bicycle backwards
boom boom boom my hands can be kind of
hip distance apart so I really get it in
then I try to feel it sense what's going
on I look at it I make sure it's coming
right from you know the hips up boom
boom boom and then with the POI I try to
go right from stillness the brights
gonna start and I go boom boom boom boom
and what can help and I've seen this a
lot is that if you keep doing it till
you ease off don't see people to get it
at first ago and then what they've done
is they've done like two repetitions of
split time and then ten repetitions at
the same time and that that won't get
you there so what works better is this
right left right left okay stop you did
it
awesome even right left okay stop
success right mmm
right left right okay stop more success
and you build your way up like that so
before long you've got right left right
left okay steps up and then you've got
right left right left right left right
like a stop and keep stopping before it
doesn't work the only other thing we're
gonna go flying over to the Statue the
other thing that I would say is yeah
just wait a while miss real feedback
just drum on something that can be super
useful if you find a wall actually you
can feel it and feel that you're
drumming one two three four one two
three four that makes a big difference
so I'll try to brainstorm other things
but yeah I mean sometimes it takes
people something to work the it split
them but try that that doesn't work I'll
think of more things let me know